Please welcome back to the show, Molly Sims!
(crowd cheers and claps)
I love your dress.
Thank you.
you look so cute.
How are you?
I'm...
I'm going in.
Winning.
Totally.
Okay, you have a daughter now.
And there is, there was a story...
She's gonna destroy me, literally.
Okay, so, I am in the shower.
It is team field day, which means you are a color.
I did not pick the color.
I know she doesn't want to be on the white team
with her brother, she doesn't.
Can I wear a crop top?
I call it a crop, I'm 90.
Yeah, no, midriff, crop.
Yeah, midriff crop.
A Sandy Duncan
A Sandy Duncan.
So we did the Sandy Duncan.
Sandy Duncan.
I'm like, you can't do it.
So I'm in the shower, she takes my phone.
She literally finds her teacher, starts texting,
"Can I wear", the end statement is a belly shirt,
but it is, you cannot, you cannot read,
can't spell wear, wear
can Scarlett (stutters)
So she texts her teacher. "Can Scarlet wear a belly shirt."
She...
I love that.
It's haha, go for it girl.
She thinks it's me. I'm like, what?
(crowd claps)
Anyway.
I love this, "Scarlett stole my phone.
I was in the shower. Lord."
I'm like, this is not me.
Yes, she's going to kill me.
Tell us about your podcast "Lipstick on the Rim".
"Lipstick on the Rim."
Great title, by the way.
Thank you.
Really great title.
(crowd cheers and claps)
And so it's called "Lipstick on the..." (chuckles)
It's called "Lipstick on the Rim."
We talk, we drink and we talk about beauty and wellness
and I do it with my best friend, Emese Gormley,
who's living now in New Jersey with her three young girls
and we bond, we connect, we talk, you know,
everything we have, like you,
you get so many amazing experts on.
And so to have, I am the listener going along
as you are when you're with people, like I'm learning.
I'm learning from the Pimple Popper or Dr. Will Cole
or what are the best products or do you do Botox?
I love Will Cole, I love the Pimple Popper.
You do?
Like I...
I know.
There was a video they did
about popping things on the lips.
I was like...
and I was like, oh God, I can't stop watching.
I know.
I had Jordan Geller, who's my endocrinologist.
I had a massive thyroid problem.
I didn't find out until I was...
I weighed 204 going into Cedars on June 19th, 2012.
I didn't realize I had a,
I don't know how I didn't realize,
I had a massive thyroid problem
and so I have gone to him for the past 10 years
and just learning about hormones and thyroid
it's been... and it's helped me.
I didn't know that my hair was falling out.
You don't know the questions to ask or the people to see.
So things like that, that I can help women and men
but also talking like,
just also being girlfriends and sharing the connection
of really lame superficial things about the best lipstick.
So, it's good.
I mean, one of the things I love about you
is your sense of humor, your lack of judgment
and just the way that you live your life out there.
It's so refreshing.
I'm always so drawn to your light.
(upbeat theme music)